في هذه البوابه من خلفي يستمر تدفق الاف
السودانيين الذين ياتون بشكل يومي هربا من
احداث الحرب في السودان الى الحدود
المصريه وعلى بعد امتار وعلى الجانب الاخر
من البوابه هناك العشرات من السودانيين
الذين ينتظرون للمرور من الحدود المصريه
وصولا الى السودان
القادمون يتوجهون الى الحافلات وعلى
وجوههم ملامح الارهاق الممزوجه بالطمانينه
فقد وصلوا الى مصر بعد رحله معاناه طويله
تاركين خلفهم مشاهد القتل والدمار واصوات
الرصاص والقذائف بيتفاجئوا بسودانيين
اخرين يستعدون للعوده لما كانوا فيه
بيوتهم فلوسنا في بيوت يعني ذهبنا احنا
طلع بيها لكن في حاجات كثيره موجوده هناك
في نفس يعني حصلت عمرهم مش ممكن يخلوها في
كثير ناس راجعه تشوف حقتها يعني مش ممكن
فجاه من زيرو ففي اماكن فيها الوضع اوكي
وفي اماكن الوضع فيها سيل يعني الخرطوم
وبحري الاماكن اللي احنا فيها للغايه
الحافلات التي تستعد للتوجه الى اسوان
والقاهره تقف بموازاه حافلات اخرى تستعد
للتوجه الى بورت سودان والخرطوم وداخلها
يجلس مواطنون يشعرون بالتعب من الانتظار
لايام للعوده ولكنهم يشعرون ايضا بالف
بالرجوع الى ديارهم واسرهم في السودان تحت
مرمى النيران يعني حيكون الهروب
مع بلدنا الحياه اللي عايزين نعملها
نعملها مع بعض احنا
كنا ما نطلع برا لانه الهروب ده
ناتج الاولاد في السودان
كلكم تعلم الاحداث الجاريه في السودان في
الوقت الراهن يعني نزوح وما ادراك
يعني نرجع لاولادنا يعني
يومين في المعبر نسبه التقدس الكبير
للناس الجايين من اتجاه السودان الخشن
لمصر الاجراءات والمواقع الخاصه بعمليات
الجوازات
والتاشيرات قد تكون كانت غير جاهزه بالشكل
المطلوب وما بين بوابتي الوصول والمغادره
يتشارك الجميع في امل انتهاء كابوس
الاشتباكات الدمويه وعوده الهدوء
والاستقرار للسودان لتبقى ذكريات هذه
الايام وما خلفته من قتلى وجرحى مرتبطه
بمعبر ارجيل الذي بات يشتهر بكونه محطه
التقاء لسودانيين الطروا للانتظار
للعبور الى ما اختاروه من مصير احمد عثمان
العربيه من امام معبر ارجين على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات